[Music]
if you had to pick a place to be sick
you could do worse than choose Germany
the country with lots of hospitals and
lots of beds normally we don't keep them
waiting some like we say next week
ourselves and what seemed to be lots of
happy patients but is a health system
long regarded as the prototype for
modern care still the gold standard of
Europe the amount of money that is in
the system may be on a very high level
the way the money is spent is not
convincing or is the German Health
Service in need of a checkup of its own
[Music]
[Music]
you see this on each war always the same
reanimation set and in case in case of a
resuscitation there's a team for each
ward coming taking that and running to
the patient efficiency has literally
been built into the structure of the
Helios Berlin book hospital one of
Germany's largest and busiest we're
operating theatres have been constructed
next to each other to allow doctors to
move swiftly between them and carry out
multiple surgeries where hidden
corridors allow seriously ill patients
to be transported quickly away from the
bustle of visitors and where you'd be
hard-pressed on any day of the year to
find patients waiting in the corridors
for beds in our Hospital perhaps every
two years the medical director here is
proud of the fact that in his hospital
operations that you could wait weeks
possibly months for in the UK are done
in days
have long waiting times we don't have of
these problems we invest we built we get
bigger if it's needed but I always hear
and see when I'm in the UK is that that
obviously there's not enough investment
in the system you need to put money into
a hospital to keep it running keep it
modern buy new machinery like other
hospitals in the German capital Helios
has extra capacity extra beds for
critical periods a product of a well
resourced system which allows patients
to get treated quickly in fact almost
too quickly for Dirk Conrad who we found
recovering from a non emergency heart
procedure he barely had time to get used
to the idea of surgery before he was on
the operating table
I was waiting at home for a week I could
have been at home for longer but this
way I had it behind me
so the appointment was okay it happened
too fast is not an observation your tier
in all national healthcare systems still
mr. Conrad will have plenty of time as
an inpatient to get over the shock
Germans spend much longer recovering in
hospital than patients in the UK don't
forget a lot of patients like to be in
the hospital sometimes I have a problem
to tell them no you're ready you can go
homes at all can I please stay another 2
or 3 days it's nice here the speed of
surgery the long stays in hospital the
cutting-edge equipment thanks in part to
a historically well-funded Health System
in Germany dating back more than a
century where money is ring-fenced and
where workers have insurance payments
deducted its source
it's this man the first Chancellor of
the German Empire Otto von Bismarck
who's credited with laying the
foundations of what is the modern
European welfare state his 1883 Health
Insurance Act compelled workers to set
aside a portion of their income to
protect them from the costs of future
sickness the model persists to today and
is based on the principle of solidarity
so the young helps support the old the
better of help support the less well-off
and workers and employers now share the
costs and it works
compulsory health insurance guarantee
high-quality medical care to almost all
of Germany's 82 million citizens have
taken from the workers wages the other
half from their employer polls
consistently say most people are happy
with the service they get our strength
is that we have full coverage of some
90% of the population these people
contribution to a sickness fund
generating income isn't everything the
demographics of Germany are changing the
population is aging and the way money is
spent is now under fierce scrutiny so
our system really likes to act and for
example to operate whenever the
opportunity is there so we do have the
highest level of substitutes for needs
substitutes for hips but everything
would which is connected was long-term
care is a very weak point and we have
freely difficulties to to keep step with
the huge amount of people in need of
care and nursing tried a couple of hours
from Berlin to the rural area of temp
lien and it's easy to see the changing
face of this nation this is where German
Chancellor Angela Merkel grew up and
where her mother still lives as part of
a growing elderly population the young
are leaving gravitating to the bigger
towns and cities family support
structures are breaking down
and so in Templin nurses are taking part
in a multimillion-pound trial to take
care into the community a relatively
undeveloped area in Germany here case
manager evening Steffler assesses the
needs of a 70 year old woman being
helped to stay in her own home after
breast cancer she's got a care status
through us with it she gets an assistant
who helps her at home she helps with
home tasks hygiene helps with carrying
her shopping because she can't take it
up the stairs yeah I mean everybody
wants to stay at home and nobody wants
to go into a care home absolutely nobody
does okay I wouldn't think it is perhaps
surprising in a country which has one of
the oldest populations in the world that
long-term care for the elderly lags
behind other European nations like the
UK dr. Hans Joachim helming oversees the
trial in Templin and has a start warning
for Germany about the urgent need for
health care reform he probably wasn't
Lana but people always just thought that
things would just work themselves out
now we realize that it is almost too
late but we have to react now because
things are sharply escalating the people
are getting older and older and the
number of young people going into health
care professions is declining and the
number of young people who can pay for
the health care system is declining up
the pressures on the system are not lost
on those who could soon themselves be
more dependent on care at the Templin
seniors club there's plenty of praise
but also concern about a health service
which they've spent decades contributing
to will it deliver when they need it
most
I hope so I heard so you shouldn't
always assume the worst what do you guys
think well the health system gets better
or worse I would say I have a good
feeling about it there is a lot of
discussion about it's on the television
and there are a lot of promises being
made but often they are not kept and
that is the problem this is the problem
and the need to care for an aging
population highlights one of the
critical weaknesses in German health
a lack of nurses tens of thousands more
are needed in the German nursing council
forecast there will be a shortage of
300,000 trained professionals by 2030
unless something is done this scheme
care tiger in Berlin is trying to draw
more people into the profession by
making the job more attractive it
communicates with nurses via a
smartphone app sending them jobs close
to homes our nurse Christine she opens
the app she chooses the client we left
the office to go out and meet nurse
Christine and trainee Sebastian on their
rounds they can get two jobs on two
wheels and get to know many of their
patients well Christine worked in
hospitals for years and understands why
people are turning away from nursing
which has long been poorly paid time the
pressure the money you cannot complete
the family and the job together it's
very difficult and it's a flokati are
very different we have so much time for
the family for my daughter and for the
patients in Sebastian who's at the start
of his career is already wondering if
his insurance payments will get him the
care he needs thank you I think when I
reached the age of the people I care for
we will still have an acute personnel
problem I don't think that will change
in the next few decades it'll take more
than private local initiatives to halt
what some say is an impending nursing
crisis here could Germany look to the UK
for some answers
I spent 10 years in England in Yorkshire
I came to work for my first job at Hull
Royal Infirmary and went through GP
training and then finally worked as a GP
in three fields in Yorkshire Stuttgart
GP dr. Christian Savile scheme is a
great admirer of the NHS where he says
nurses do more take on greater
responsibility have better career
prospects in the UK minor illnesses are
being treated in the by a nurse
practitioners for example and there are
even prescribing nurses for example so
even for the prescription you don't need
necessarily the doctor in person to be
there you can delegate vaccinations so
there are a lot of interesting points we
can learn from the English system really
the ability to delegate work would take
pressure off dr. Cebulski
you like other GPS in Germany runs a
single doctor practice as a business on
top of medicine he is weighed down by
bureaucracy pursuing money from a
multitude of sickness funds who pay him
for each patient he sees and those
insurance companies are themselves now
trying to control costs setting limits
on the number of people he can have on
his books a lot of time is spent writing
the bills basically is seeing how you
get your money I found it very easy in
the NHS where you don't have to think as
much about how to build people you know
so there is much much more time spent
thinking how to get the patient well
people in Germany have the freedom to
visit any and as many GPS and
specialists as they want and so-called
doctor hopping adds to the burgeoning
costs the country's health care system
is one of the most expensive in the
world and spending is fueled by advances
in technology where Germany has been at
the forefront so this is one of our new
intensive care rooms at Charity Berlin
it is a whole new concept to t velop an
ICU environment that enables us to keep
sick patients awake but without stress
at the same time one of the country's
top teaching and research hospitals
they're taking a new approach to
intensive care
sophisticated light panels are used as
part of the healing process
synchronizing patients today and night
crucially patients are not fully sedated
we know that when we are sedating
patients those patient have a higher
risk of hospital mortality they have a
higher risk for developing acute brain
dysfunction and in the long term
cognitive and physical disabilities the
aim is to improve patient outcome but it
could also cut costs by preventing this
cognitive and physical dysfunctions we
can reduce ICU length of stay duration
for mechanical ventilation and the
hospital stay in total and that would
also reduce healthcare costs of course
if Germany is to keep investing in
research there will need to be
rationalization in the health system it
could mean painful choices closing
smaller hospitals restricting choice
finding alternatives to operations
change is needed distribution of money
that goes into the system there is not
on a fair level and it's not on a level
that is reflecting the objective demands
the Bismarck model has proved remarkably
resilient but he could never have
imagined when he set it up the workers
would survive the illnesses which
routinely killed people in the 19th
century the medical equipment would
evolve beyond scalpels and needles to
the high-tech and highly costly
equipment we see today and that so many
Germans would live to be 80 90 100 GM
anis health service is still one of the
best in the world but in 2018 it isn't
perfect
Michelle Clifford Sky News Germany
[Music]